يتظاهرون يوميا تقريبا همهم الاكبر العثور
على فرصه عمل حكوميه
واحد من هؤلاء مهندسا في شركه خاصه يرى ان
العمل في القطاع الخاص لا يشكل ضمانه
لمستقبله عكس العمل في القطاع الحكومي كل
وظائف الحكوميه مضمونه بها راتب تقاعدي
زين بالاضافه الى ضعف القطاع الخاص وعدم
وجود قانون يحمي القطاع الخاص
اصبح مشكله كبيره تسببت في ارتفاع مستوى
البطاله في العراق
ودفعها هؤلاء الشباب وغيرهم الى استمرار
التظاهري طلبا للوظيفه الحكوميه
في حد هذه اللحظه الحكومه لم تتعامل بشكل
جدي مع القطاع الخاص كل ما تزداد الدعوات
باتجاه حريه السوق والتوجه نحو واقتصاد
السوق كل ما تزداد اجراءات الحكومه مركزيه
نحتاج الى انه اعاده النظر بالقوانين
المنظمه للعمل في القطاع الخاص بحيث تكون
محفزه ومشجعه يقولوا مسؤولون ان القطاع
العام تضخم اكثر مما يجب ان يقدروا عدده
العاملين فيه بنحو اربعه ملايين ونصف
مليون شخص وهو تقريبا عدد المتقاعدين من
بحسب بيانات الرسميه بينما تلتهم الرواتب
والاجور نحو 60% من الموازنه الاتحاديه
مسؤولون في وزاره العمل
ضروره بعثت القطاع الخاص وتحديث منظومته
التشريعيه التي تعود الى عام 1971
وهي غير قادره اليوم على الاستجابه
بمتطلبات المرحله الراهنه اقتصاديا
واجتماعيا
والاول امتصاص البطاله هو بتشريع صراع
بتشريح قانون التقاعد والضمان الاجتماعي
للعمال راح يخف الضغط على ال ال الحكومه
وايضا تشغيل المشاريع الخاصه فاني لو شغلت
كل هالقطات واعطيتهم كلها المساحه بالعمل
وشرعت القانون وضمانه اضمن لك انه البطاله
راحت تقريبا شبه تنعدم
ورحمه تبني العراق الحريه الاقتصاديه
واقتصاد السوق منذ نحو عقدين من الزمن ما
زال القطاع العام مهيمنا مع تهميش دوري
القطاع الخاص على الصعيدين الاجتماعي
والاقتصادي وليد ابراهيم الجزيره البغدادي